In today's lesson we will learn English
with Billie Eilish's hit new song
"No time to die" from the new Bond film
So Billie joins legendary artists like
Adele
Sam Smith and Madonna in having the
honor to do the bond title song.
Let's hear a little bit about what Billy says
about her recent explosion of success
It feels like I'm in the dream and I'm
gonna wake up and it'll all be over and
I'll still be a little pimply 11
year-old
So being a huge Billie Eilish
fan myself I was really excited to get
to do this lesson for you so if you're a
Billie Eilish fan too be sure to give this
video a like let us know that you want
more lessons with Billy and her music
and before we learn with the first part
of the song I wanna let you know that if
you're new here every week we make fun
lessons with your favorite movies, TV
series, songs and so much more so that
you can understand fast speaking natives
without getting lost without missing
the jokes and without subtitles.
like Neelam who says that our lessons
gave him the confidence that he needed
to speak English
and your English
comprehension and confidence are going
to increased a ton too, just hit that
subscribe button and the bell down below so
you don't miss any of our new lessons
So I know you're watching
this lesson because you've been
frustrated when you can't understand
natives whether it's in music, TV series
movies or even in real life
conversations. And this hurts your
confidence, you're scared of actually
using your English in real life you want
to be able to confidently understand
natives in any situation just like your
mother tongue right? Well this is exactly
why we created our Fluid with Friends
course our goal for you with this course
is to be able to learn the principles of
real native speech so that you can
understand natives no matter how fast we
speak and have a lot of fun doing it now
in this 40 week course you will learn
alongside the first two seasons of the
TV series friends with innovative tools
like power lessons vocabulary
memorization software and more and you
even get access to our global community
of English learners: the Fluency Circle
so do you want to try it? Well you can do
that for free with our three-part master
class all you have to do is click up
here or down in the description below and
you can learn more and sign up for that
right now
Hey would you like us to make more
lessons with Billie?
Well then remember to give this video a
like down below and also comment down
below and let us know which song would
you like us to make a lesson with
So Billie
is not only a great singer but she also
is quite funny so you'll definitely want
to check out this other lesson that we
recently made with Billie on The Ellen
Show you can check that out by clicking
up here or down the script below after
you finish this lesson
All right I hope that you enjoyed
learning with this lesson as much as we
enjoyed making it for you. Now remember
to comment down below and let me know
which Billie Eilish songs you would like
us to make a lesson with, and continue on
your English journey with one of these
lessons over here that I know you're
going to love and now it's time to go
beyond the classroom and live your English
Aww yeah!